the recent autodesk session revealed
quite a bit of information about
hogwarts legacy professors including
some 100 confirmations and then some
other details that have allowed us to
speculate even further so we're going to
start with the ones we're most confident
in and then work our way up to the ones
that still have the biggest question
marks at number one we have abraham
ronan professor of charms and this one
is 100 confirmed thanks to hogwarts
legacy community manager chandler wood
the speculation started when this scene
right here was shown during the autodesk
which was basically just a scene showing
off how avalanche is able to create
characters for hogwarts legacy what it
also showed is the name here his house
and of course a character that we
recognized from the trailer here many
had also speculated that he was in
slytherin largely due to the snakes on
his clothing here and chandler wood
would go on to 100 confirm all of this
on twitter shortly after it was shown in
the autodesk presentation so that one is
as solid of a lock as we get guys and up
next we have history of magic professor
cuthbert bins all right look i think i'm
gonna put this one at 99 percent
confirmed i'm only going to leave that
one percent because no one at avalanche
has officially stated as they did with
ronan and charms but long time the fans
of the series know this is just about as
much confirmation pretty much a virtual
lock as there are some clear indications
that this ghost here is professor bin's
and that this is the history of magic
classroom i mean just look at these
bored and uninterested students which
was a frequent occurrence in the harry
potter series as ben's as not known as
one of the most engaging professors now
we had a pretty good feeling even before
the trailers that bins was most likely
going to be the history of magic
professor but we weren't 100 sure
because we didn't know the exact date he
died and for a while we didn't know the
exact date that the game took place but
seeing this here again will put it at a
99 confirmation we also know this
character here is the enigmatic
professor eliezer fig and that he'll
play a key role in helping us get
acquainted with hogwarts what we don't
know is the specific subject he teaches
one of the most common guesses is the
study of ancient runes which would
certainly make sense considering that he
appears to be aiding our character in
understanding our connection to ancient
magic if it's not ancient runes my money
is on transfiguration and that's almost
purely due to the process of elimination
which you'll see more of as we move
through this list if we had to put
percentages on it i would say the odds
are at about 75 that fig is the study of
ancient ruins professor 20 for
transfiguration and maybe five percent
for something no one is expecting like
maybe muggle studies next we're gonna
move into a category where we have a few
appearances but only speculation when it
comes to the names let's start with the
potions master here he's actually made
an appearance in both trailers and given
his body language in some of these
scenes the immediate impression is a
teacher who may be somewhat abrasive not
unlike another famous potions master we
all know and some even kind of love
[Music]
there's been quite a bit of speculation
on this character being phineas black
starting with the fact that he bears a
striking resemblance to gary oldman's
portrayal of sirius black in the harry
potter films there's also that surly
demeanor i talked about which would fit
for phineas as well as the green tie
which could indicate he's a slytherin
but that's certainly no guarantee after
all professor ronan is a confirmed
slytherin and we see him wearing a
striking purple i mean i get it it's
logical to see the colors that they're
wearing and automatically assume oh it
relates to the house but if you think
about over the course of a school year
they're people i mean they're going to
be wearing lots of different colors not
always dressed exactly in line with
their house all that being said i was
completely sold on this being professor
black i really thought that it was going
to be him and then that maybe we were
going to get eupraxia mole as the
headmistress in the recent autodesk
presentation however a wrench was thrown
into this theory thanks to the file name
that eagle-eyed fans caught during the
presentation so here's the file name in
question i'm not gonna read through all
of it but just to sum up here fbx files
are 3d model files saved in the autodesk
film box format and honestly it's hard
to deny that this is most likely in
reference to the name of the hogwarts
legacy potions professor and in that
case it would appear to be professor
sharp not professor black so i'll say
100 chance this is our potions professor
and given the file names i'll say a 70
chance his surname is sharp or something
close to it speaking of professor black
his name did appear in another file name
we happen to see during the autodesk
presentation but if the potions master
here is professor sharp then our most
likely candidate for phineas black would
be this professor here which would also
mean it's highly likely that he is the
headmaster for hogwarts legacy now just
in case you're wondering the professor
black file name we saw did not indicate
any subject as we saw with professor
sharp which again would kind of
reinforce the fact that he's not a
professor of a specific subject but
instead is the headmaster of the school
given what we know from harry potter
canon about the timeline and history of
hogwarts black has always been one of
the two most likely candidates for the
headmaster post in hogwarts legacy
alongside upraxia mole but this
particular professor certainly fits the
description of phineas from the book
which further bolsters the evidence that
he's the guy now if this is indeed the
case it will be super interesting to see
how avalanche portrays black who will be
almost the antithesis of albus
dumbledore the hogwarts headmaster that
most fans are familiar with we know
black did not care much for teaching and
even grew to loathe students the more
time he spent in the school he also had
strong anti-muggle views largely in line
with those of salazar slytherin i'll say
the chances of this being both black and
the headmaster are pretty high let's say
70 percent with an outside shot that the
potions master is actually black and the
file names are just leading us in the
wrong direction another professor which
we know the appearance on but not for
sure on the name is our defense against
the dark arts professor we get a brief
look at her in the dueling scene here
which is set in the dark arts classroom
there weren't many solid guesses to her
name until the autodesk session which
like professor sharp and potions also
gave us a similar file name for the
defense against the dark arts professor
which reads professor hecate this could
certainly be a reference to the greek
goddess hecate although it's worth
pointing out the file name did not have
an e on the end so either the
pronunciation could be slightly
different or maybe the spelling is just
changed or it could be that the file
name doesn't actually show the full last
name perhaps for some reason the file
name is limited to five characters for
the last name as both sharp and black
are also only five letters probably not
the case but just i don't know random
observation that i thought i should
point out for the odds here i'll say 100
that she's the defense against the dark
arts professor and like sharp i'll give
it 70 odds that her last name is hecate
or some variation of that and now we get
to what i think is one of the most fun
and surprising professors and it's the
witch we see with the sorting hat and
also in the room of requirement could
this character actually be named
professor weasley well i think so guys
and here's why during the autodesk
presentation there was a super
interesting segment about the motion
capture for the game and the
difficulties that they faced due to the
pandemic honestly it was really quite
incredible to see the links that they
had to go to to make this work but in
one of these shots we get a brief look
at a scene between one motion capture
artist that's clearly serving as the
player character and another that
appears to have the role of a weasley as
noted by the text above her head here
from there we can compare the appearance
of her character which appears to be the
very same character model of the witch
with the sorting hat just take a look at
the scarf and the clothing the hair i
mean even down to the number of buttons
i think this one is looking pretty dead
on now avalanche also confirmed in the
playstation blog we would be meeting up
with a weasley or two in hogwarts legacy
it could be a really fun dynamic to see
one of them being a professor and the
other being a student so i'm gonna say
85 chance this is professor weasley as
first subject i think it comes down to
transfiguration muggle studies or
possibly ancient runes if that one
doesn't go to fig gotta consider
arithmancy as well and of those i think
i'll put transfiguration as being the
most likely at a 60 chance of course
because of the red hair i totally get
why some are speculating that this our
herbology professor seen here is
actually a weasley i mean they did
pretty much tell us there are going to
be multiple weasleys in the game maybe
there are two professors that are
weasleys i don't think so though if i
had to guess on this professor's
identity my prediction would be helen
thistlewood now if you've only started
following hogwarts legacy recently that
name probably doesn't mean anything to
you well if you've been following the
game for a while you may remember it
because it actually popped up on an imdb
a while back which yes i know imdb not
official so let's be completely clear
about that but there was an update there
from an actress by the name of julia
farino and it was said that she would be
voicing two characters for hogwarts
legacy one a character by the name of
cassandra mason and the other a
character by the name of helen
thistlewood and i mean come on after
having a professor sprout for the
herbology teacher during harry potter's
day a professor thistlewood would really
fit and would make a lot of sense here
now if you want to do a little bit
further digging on this there are a few
clips of julia online where you can
actually hear her speaking and i can
definitely hear the similarities in her
voice to the herbology professor of
course i mean these actors are super
talented they can change their voice
like crazy so who knows but i'm gonna
say 100 chance this is the herbology
professor and 50 chance her name is
helen thistle would up next we have care
of magical creatures we very well may
have gotten this professor's name
through one of the concept art images of
the game it was this shot here and a
sharpened zoomed in image of that that
makes the text much easier to read and
then you can see it says professor
ernesto jags veterinary supplies now
with this one i think it's important to
remember that this is a piece of concept
art we have no idea how early in the
process this art was created and whether
or not they had even finalized all of
the professor names yet i'd be
comfortable saying there's probably
maybe a 60 chance this stayed the name
all the way through development but then
what about his identity well from what
we've seen in the trailers there aren't
too many options left he could be a
character we simply haven't seen yet
some people think it could be this
gentleman here that we see in that scene
with sebastian while others think this
could just be sebastian's father or
maybe someone related to sebastian or
who knows it could in fact be professor
jag but moving on from care of magical
creatures when it comes to other
appearances of professors that we see in
the trailers i think there are two
others that we see first the flying
professor here which first time seeing
this i think a lot of people thought in
this shot here this was actually a
student but then in this scene here the
sorting ceremony if you look in the
background i mean this looks exactly
like the same person so i think that is
in fact the flying professor and then
same scene just shift over to the right
this which here is almost certainly
either the divination or astronomy
professor i think divination has
slightly higher odds over astronomy i'm
not really sure why just kind of a gut
feel more than anything i'll say 60
divination 40 chance for astronomy and
as for the other subjects we may see in
hogwarts legacy i'll throw out both
arithmancy and muggle studies which
would be really interesting to see how
they would handle that one right so far
confirmed we have care magical creatures
charms defense against the dark arts
herbology history of magic potions all
of those are confirmed classes we can
take in hogwarts legacy you gotta think
that divination is pretty likely as well
given the recent tweet about the
divination tower and i would put
transfiguration up there as being highly
probable as well considering this brief
shot from the announcement trailer i
mean that is definitely some
transfiguration going on right there now
all of this information we went over
about professors was kind of just the
tip of the iceberg when it comes to this
autodesk session if you want to hear
even more about what was shown there
including a brand new cutscene and check
out the video on the right side of your
screen now as always thank you all so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon